would you like a drink I'm sorry what  was they thinking  bad for the public image right mr. key  to the city what did you do to her I did  what you failed to do I was there for  her  mary-jane and I understand each other  she doesn't know what you are Peter she  knows me very well and when she kissed  me he was just like she used to kiss me  but tastes strawberries  how'd you like that Spidey  [Music]  and all you guys  [Music]  Sting's doesn't it protected you in high  school now I'm gonna kick your little  ass  [Music]  [Music]  gonna kill me like you killed my father  I'm trying to convince you you took him  from me he loved me  no he despised you you were an  embarrassment to him huh lucky little  Kaplan junior gonna cry  [Music]  you